a new book on the trump presidency is
unlike anything you've seen before
here's what the author wrote a few days
ago and The Hollywood Reporter Donald
Trump is staking his presidency as he
did his election on nothing less than
destroying the credibility of the news
media and the media are determined to do
the same to him only one side can
achieve victory to a stunning degree the
press is falling into the president's
trap we're delighted to welcome the
writer of that piece Howie Kurtz the
host of media buzz on Fox News and the
author of a soon to be huge New York
Times best seller media madness Donald
Trump the press and the war over the
truth Howie there's so many nuggets in
here we've got to get to and I loved
your piece in The Hollywood Reporter I
found this element from John Martin
Jonathan Martin from The New York Times
that you captured in your book to be
stunning weeks before the convention an
RNC staff member called Martin one night
to challenge one of his stories the
reporter shot back you're a racist in a
fascist Donald Trump is a racist in a
fascist we all know it and you're
complicit by reporting him you're all
culpable speiser called a top times
editor and unloaded about Jonathan
Martin's behavior half an hour later
Martin called speiser and demanded how
dare you go behind my back what are you
doing calling one of my editors excuse
me
spicy replied you call one of my people
and say this and I don't have the right
to complain Jonathan Martin is one of
the top writers at the New York Times
yeah he's a good reporter but I have
four sources with first-hand knowledge
including the RNC staffer that had this
conversation we'll actually two
conversations that confirm this for me
and obviously now Jonathan Martin is
disputing it since the book came out he
says he can't imagine saying such a
thing but spicer Sean Spicer went on a
radio show today Oh today and confirmed
on the record that my count is accurate
well he is not only such an important
reporter for the New York Times but his
accounts of the campaign are then
repeated and taken by other reporters
and run with so when he's reporting on a
candidate like Trump and now the
presidency he thinks Trump's a racist
and a fascist you must have the you must
have a desire to remove
a racist and a fascist from office you
know I have a lot of exclusive reporting
in this book about what other
journalists say about the president on
Twitter when they think that only their
friends are kind of following it right
and I think that one of the problems
here look there's been a lot of
legitimate stories about the president
sometimes the president creates his own
distractions but I think that too many
people journalists now think it's their
job to save the country from Donald
Trump that's not journalism that's
advocacy it's crusading and it's fine
when your pundit or your you know take
the chart take the hill but it's it's
disconcerting and the public's view of
the press today Howie where is it today
versus ten years ago has it declined
oh it's dramatically declined that it's
it's dramatically declined even further
since then all Trump was a candidate and
now president because of people who
support this president the big chunk of
the country feel that one twenty five
percent now when the mainstream media
attacks him they also feel like the
mainstream media treat them with disdain
and so what no one has understood is
that negative coverage of the Donald
Trump campaign and as president actually
helps him because he controls the news
agenda because we love to write about
ourselves and because it strikes a nerve
with his supporters yesterday when he
left for Davos when he reminded me of
your book because Maggie Haberman says
something about you know testifying
you're gonna testify under oath and he
said who said that I think it was Maggie
Haberman and the back-and-forth sure any
and he said well you know did you know
if Hillary just testified under oath did
she was she questioned under oath well I
don't know you don't know like it's like
a bar fight with him with a member of
the press but is that always smart it's
often smart that he's his own spokesman
even though he talks in a street
language it's not always smart to tack
journalists individually because I think
it it creates distractions but I think
there's damage on both sides you got to
read by this book to read about Steve
ban and what he warned about regarding
impeachment phenomenal Howie Kurtz